[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic les mathématiques de la relativité
générale partie 4 métriques autre modèle
mathématique est de plus en plus précis
on a construit un système de coordonnées
une grille qui repère la position des
objets on a défini la notion de temps
propre pour interpréter la ligne
d'univers comme un mouvement dans
l'espace temps et on a obtenu une
première équation fondamentale
l'équation des géodésique qui prédit la
trajectoire des objets à condition de
connaître les symboles de christophe
elle cependant un problème persiste nos
coordonnées bien qu'ils repèrent des
points ne nous donnent aucune
information quant aux distances et aux
angles réel qui sépare les objets en
effet une case sur la grille ne
représente pas partout la même distance
ni la même orientation et il va falloir
en tenir compte
[Musique]
pour ce faire imaginons deux points sur
la feuille très rapprochés l'un de
l'autre à partir des coordonnées de ces
deux points on désire exprimer la
distance qui les sépare à première vue
on peut penser au théorème de pythagore
en notant des x 0 et dx11 les écarts de
coordonnées qui sépare les deux points
on aurait envie d'écrire que le carré de
la distance ds est égale à la somme des
carrés des deux côtés mais le théorème
de pythagore ne s'applique que si les
cases de la grille forme d'un repère
orthonormé si les cases sont plus
petites aux plus grandes ou que leur sac
ce ne sont pas orthogonaux le théorème
de pythagore ne fonctionne plus et il
faut trouver une expression plus général
qui fonctionne quelle que soit la forme
des cases
dans le cas général on peut montrer que
le carré de la distance peut toujours
s'écrire comme une somme de toutes les
combinaisons possibles de deux côtés x
des coefficients ces coefficients
dépendent directement de la forme des
cases dans le cas précis où les cases
sont des carrés de côté 1
les coefficients valent respectivement 1
0 0 et 1
on retrouve alors le théorème de
pythagore dans le cas général on peut
réunir les composantes qui correspondent
à chacun de ces termes dans un tableau
avec une vigne et une colonne pour
chaque coordonnées on appelle cet objet
le temps soeur métriques sa
représentation est un tableau dont les
composantes nous permettent de calculer
des petites distances
habituellement ce tableau est notée
petits jets et on numérote chacune de
ses composantes par les deux indices
respectifs
dans le cas général on peut donc écrire
le carré de la distance qui sépare les
deux points comme la somme de chaque
composante du tableau x les deux écarts
de coordonnées qui correspondent à ces
deux indices
[Musique]
en utilisant cette formule on peut
notamment exprimé la norme du vecteur
vitesse pour ce faire on remplace les
écarts de coordonnées par les
composantes du vecteur en se souvenant
que la norme de la vitesse est toujours
égale à celle de la lumière
on peut écrire une nouvelle version de
cette équation plus précise
[Musique]
il est très important de comprendre que
le temps soeur métriques est un outil
fondamental dans la théorie de la
relativité générale
en effet pour le moment nous n'avions
que des coordonnées des nombreux
abstrait et descriptions mathématiques
qui ne représente rien de
fondamentalement concrets grâce au temps
soeur métriques
on peut transformer ses descriptions
abstraites en de vraies mesures de
distance et d'angles le temps soeur
métriques est donc la clé qui va nous
permettre de relier les mathématiques à
la géométrie
pour finir
reprenons l'équation des géodésique on a
vu que cette équation prédit la
trajectoire d'un objet à condition de
connaître la valeur des symboles de
christophe elle mais pour le moment rien
ne nous donnait la valeur de ses
symboles et il était donc impossible
d'utiliser l'équation
il se trouve que ce tableau le temps
soeur métriques va justement nous
permettre de calculer les symboles de
christophe elle en effet on a vu
précédemment que les symboles de
christophe elles correspondent aux
variations des vecteurs de base le long
des coordonnées mais ces variations se
traduise directement par un changement
dans la forme des cases sur la grille et
comme on l'a vu la forme des cases va
directement affectés les coefficients du
tenseur métriques
en mesurant la variation du tenseur
métriques le long de la grille on peut
ainsi déterminer les variations
d'inclinaison des vecteurs de base et
par conséquent les symboles de
christophe elle grâce au temps soeur
métriques
on va désormais pouvoir exprimer la
valeur des symboles et ainsi utiliser
notre équation lorsqu'on effectue ce
calcul qui prend en compte la variation
du tenseur métriques pour exprimer les
symboles de christophe l on obtient une
expression relativement complexe qui
fait intervenir des dérivés du tenseur
métriques caron la déplacer le long des
coordonnées mais également son inverse
que l'on note avec des indices en eau et
qui est un autre tableau complexe à
calculer cela dit dans la majorité des
cas on peut simplifier cette expression
en choisissant le bon système de
coordonnées en l'occurrence on
s'arrangera pour toujours choisir une
grille dont les axes sont
perpendiculaires entre eux
avec une telle grille l'expression des
symboles de christophe feltz simplifie
grandement cette expression se calcule
directement à partir des composantes du
tenseur métriques et en particulier nous
n'avons plus besoin de calculer son
inverse
à condition de connaître le temps soeur
métriques
nous sommes désormais capables de
calculer les symboles de christophe elle
est en les injectant dans l'équation des
géodésique nous sommes en mesure de
prédire la trajectoire des objets dans
l'univers en somme nous avons développé
une méthode qui décrit le mouvement d'un
corps en fonction de la géométrie de
l'espace temps la géométrie de l'espace
temps est incarnée par cet objet le
danseur métriques qui à lui seul va
décrire les rapports entre les distances
réels et nos coordonnées mais il nous
manque une méthode pour pouvoir
déterminer cette géométrie ce temps sur
mes tricks dans les vidéos qui suivent
nous allons voir comment relier le temps
soeur métriques à la courbure et au
contenu de l'espace ton
comme d'habitude résumons tous ces
concepts par un exemple concret pour
commencer reprenons l'exemple de la
terre que l'on décrit par les
coordonnées de latitude et longitude à
la surface d'une sphère par rapport à
cette grille le temps soeur métriques
peut s'exprimer comme le tableau suivant
la lettre r désigne le rayon de la
planète et les ongles et à efi
correspondent aux coordonnées de
latitude et longitude cette expression
général va nous permettre de calculer le
temps soeur métriques en n'importe quel
point de la sphère quel que soit
l'emplacement où l'on souhaite le calcul
et il suffit de remplacer d'état par la
latitude du point si l'on souhaite
mesurer des petites distances autour de
ce point on a vu précédemment qu'il
suffit d'additionner chaque composante
du tableau x les écarts de coordonner en
calculant cette somme on obtient la
valeur de dsk ray qui correspond au
carré de la distance qui sépare les deux
points cela dit le temps soeur métriques
ne nous donne accès qu'à de très petites
distances
si l'on souhaite mesurer des grandes
distances il va falloir le calcul est à
plusieurs endroits
car la forme des cases peu évolué le
long du trajet qu'on souhaite mesurer en
termes mathématiques
cela se traduit par une intégrale c'est
à dire une somme sur une infinité de
petites distances
le danseur métriques est un outil
extrêmement puissant
à partir de descriptions abstraites des
coordonnées il va nous permettre de
mesurer des vrais distance concrète à la
surface de la sphère
pour finir nous allons pouvoir appliquer
toutes ces notions géométriques un
espace temps prenons l'exemple le plus
simple d'un espace temps vide dans
lequel se déplace un objet par exemple
imaginons qu'un satellite se soient
perdus dans le vide de l'espace
pour décrire sa trajectoire
nous allons munir notre espace-temps de
deux cores donner une coordonnées de
temps tu es qui mesure le temps sur
notre horloge et une coordonnées des
espaces x qui mesurent la position du
satellite le long d'un axe
au fil de son temps propre le satellite
va pouvoir se déplacer à travers les
deux coordonnées dans un tel espace
temps vide le temps soeur métriques
prend la forme suivante ce temps soeur
métriques est relativement simple
d'autant plus qu'il ne dépend pas des
coordonnées c'est à dire qu'il est le
même partout sur la grille en
particulier comme il ne varie pas sur la
grille toutes ces dérivés sont nulles et
tous les symboles de christophe elles
valent donc zéro en les injectant dans
l'équation des géodésique on obtient
simplement que les composantes de la
vitesse du satellite ne varie pas le
satellite va se déplacer de façon
constante à travers nos coordonnées
cette métrique relativement simple qui
décrit le mouvement des objets dans un
espace temps vide
est ce qu'on appelle la métrique de
minkowski la métrique de minkowski
correspond à l'espace temps de la
relativité restreinte elle est plutôt
simple du fait qu'elle ne dépend pas des
coordonnées
l'espace temps possède la même géométrie
partout sur la grille un premier
résultat que l'on peut obtenir à partir
de la métrique de minkowski et le
phénomène de dilatation du temps
pour ce faire nous avons obtenus
précédemment une équation qui reliait la
norme de la vitesse à ses composantes en
utilisant cette équation dans le cadre
du satellite
nous allons pouvoir exprimer sa vitesse
temporel en fonction de sa vitesse
spatiale l'expression qu'on obtient est
d'autant plus grande que le satellite se
déplace vite dans l'espace cela signifie
que plus le satellite se déplacent
rapidement dans l'espace plus notre
temps va s'écouler rapidement rapport à
son temps propre
en somme plus un objet se déplace vite
dans l'espace plus son temps propres va
ralentir par rapport à notre temps
à première vue la métrique de minkebe ce
qui peut paraître banal plutôt simple
mais il ne faut pas s'y méprendre la
métrique 2015 ce qui est très
particulière
en cela qu'elle contient 1 - 1 ce - 1
est une propriété étrange est
fondamental de notre univers il nous
signifie que les dimensions des espaces
et de temps sont fondamentalement
opposés
reprenons notre satellite et mesurons la
distance qui le sépare d'un point dans
son futur
ici par exemple cette distance est de 2
secondes lumière s'il on décale ce point
dans l'espace on pourrait s'attendre à
une distance plus grande mais à cause de
ceux moins un dans la métrique
la distance est en réalité plus petit et
plus le point et décalé dans l'espace
plus cette distance diminue lorsque le
point est incliné en diagonale par
rapport aux satellites
c'est à dire qu'il parcourt autant de
temps que des espaces la distance qui
sépare le satellite du point est
étrangement 2 0 un objet se déplaçant le
long de cette diagonale
le parcours est en réalité aucune
distance dans l'espace temps et sont en
propre c'est à dire la graduation sur sa
trajectoire ne s'écoulerait pas c'est ce
qu'on appelle plus communément la
lumière
au-delà de cette diagonale les distances
deviennent des racines carrées de
nombres négatifs
ce sont des nombres imaginaire et le
satellite ne pourra jamais atteindre de
tels points la lumière
est infranchissable
[Musique]